it's a bamhi 27 degrees Celsius slightly
overcast with scarcely a breeze this
hilltop wind turbine near Castle is
normally spinning except on warm summer
days like this one the wind park
dominates the skyline from down in the
city but too much land cough has never
actually been up there his business is
virtual weather patterns he buys the
data he needs from weather services here
his estimating wind speeds in the
English Channel lon coats company enter
cast uses the data to make specialized
forecasts they're used to predict things
like a wind generators performance
equals when he visited and if I want to
know how much power I'll have tomorrow I
have to know what the weather will be we
know that and we know how the turbines
respond we do the math and we tell our
customers how much energy will reach the
grid tomorrow up on the hill things
aren't looking very energetic regional
network operator I am constantly
monitors the inter caste predictions
they come in every couple of hours 400 a
day and right now the Sun is expected to
provide more power than the wind and our
casts data helps eam to distribute the
available power more efficiently it's
like trying to avoid traffic congestion
on a highway in s biturbo engine valve
as a grid provider we're responsible to
a use more renewable energy and B make
sure we operate profitably the time you
can only do that when you've got access
to the necessary data which you then use
to keep the net running at optimal
levels as one dose would always lost
with an optimal that data is what enter
cast provides and the company is growing
rapidly revenues have doubled within the
last two years a subsidiary of energy
giant rwe has injected millions of euros
into the company that's funded for an
expansion primarily in Eastern Europe
and the United States
and enter cast has recently moved into
China as well VNV Coonskin stark we're
developing very rapidly while they
increase in renewable first of all they
make small inroads into a country we're
not needed at that point then it starts
to multiply and once they get into the
region of twenty or thirty percent
renewables are called then they need our
services and the more they expand
renewables the more important we become
to them and how's the weather back on
our hilltop the wind has peaked at a
measly five meters a second enough to
turn out 240 kilowatts of electricity by
comparison when the wind really blows
it's 3000 kilowatts but there's no
chance of that today and everyone who
had access to enter cast knew that all
along